and Cameron Johnson just one eleventh  how do you react to that news he went  way 11 cam and I'm driving yep  it's red on the screen right there Wow  Wow Wow  bro that's crazy that's so love bro cuz  ya'll know camp you don't know how hard  can work he knows a lot of people that  doubt him but Wow I'm just brought it's  such a that's crazy bro wow that's so  crazy I'm so happy for him right now I  don't understand how happy I am for cam  because he like he proved in 1990 that  he deserves to be you know in the  conversation for a lottery pick man he  shot the ball like anyone I've never  seen before in my life or played with so  I'm so it Wow bro that's great I'm  getting chills up here